just be Muslim on the streets right is
now not only just a spiritual identity
but also a political act it's an act of
resistance and resilience I definitely
feel that whenever there's an attack
anywhere as a Muslim I always have to
stand up and stand against it and say oh
well we're not Isis
we just can't mourn the victims of these
terrible tragedies and we have to almost
kind of go into this reactionary amount
of like oh my god like I hope the
perpetrators or Muslim we don't get a
chance to be human and kind of show
human emotion I really don't like the
way that we're expected to be a
political or neutral or comforting or
palatable the emotional toll the
physical toll and the psychological toll
of constantly trying to to explain
myself and prove myself is not worth it
to me there's days where I don't want to
leave the home and I push myself to
because I refuse to live like that
people like Donald Trump have left a
lasting effect he's kind of made it okay
to hate and and that's my biggest fear
I'm not going to let fear dictate my
faith at all so I don't necessarily fear
too much for myself but my mother she
does cover and I do fear for her I'm
scared for the immediate impacts of like
hate crimes on our bodies but then I'm
also scared and worried about the kind
of the more deep-seated impacts of what
these of what this climate is doing to
our sense of place and belonging
sometimes I'll wear my hijab my
headscarf in a more traditional way and
I definitely feel more visible as a
Muslim woman when I do that well I'll
style my headscarf a different way just
because I'm sort of tired of being hyper
scrutinized my five-year-old son is on
when hate unfortunately has to listen to
the news once in a while and he hears
the word Muslim Muslim Muslim Muslim and
he looks at me and goes mommy aren't we
Muslim
and I say yes we are Muslim he's like
well what about those people are they
bad guys that I can't even explain what
that feels like as a mother it's not my
job to tackle Islamophobia in the sense
that I should make people feel more
comfortable I'm not here to prove that
I'm not a terrorist or that I'm not a
violent or or on the flip side not here
to prove how Muslim I am I feel all
citizens that live in the United States
hold the responsibility to attack
Islamophobia the United States of
America from its inception has been
based on race and want entity think that
they are better than another entity
remember is less than 60 years ago that
are African Americans couldn't sit in
the front of the bus you have two
choices if you're given the choice
between what you learn on the media
versus somebody you know I would much
rather be that person to take some of
those very ignorant questions at first
so I've been brought closer to my faith
and I also feel like I've been brought
closer to standing up for injustice my
practice has been fortified y'all
haven't wavered at all you know I don't
have a lot of faith that there's going
to be a shift in the narrative that one
day Donald Trump is going to be like you
know what
my bad Muslims aren't actually that
terrible and I'm sorry I've been saying
all this awful about people I do
have hope but I think it'll be a little
different and reality there are more
decent human beings on this planet than
negative human beings that's the hope
that drives me